TONIGHT.
THE COMPREHENSIVE CALL ON.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF HOW
SERIOUS THE DEMOCRATS ARE ABOUT
THIS CRUSH GOING ON AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, LISTEN TO THE
FIRST QUESTION THAT WAS POSED BY
THE RANKING MEMBER AT TODAY'S
HOMELAND SECURITY HEARING.
>> THE WHOLE MED THREAT PICTURE
HAS SHIFTED DRAMATICALLY FROM
FOREIGN TERRORISTS TO DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS, IN PARTICULAR,
RATE -- RACIALLY MOTIVATED BY
EXTREMISTS WHO PRESENT THE MOST
LETHAL THREATS TO THE COMMENT.
WHAT IS YOUR CURRENT ASSESSMENT
OF THE DOMESTIC TERRORISM THREAT
TO OUR COUNTRY?
>> MR. CHAIRMAN, IT IS OUR
ASSESSMENT THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE EXTREMISM POSES THE
GREATEST TERRORISM RELATED
THREAT TO OUR HOMELANDS.
>> Laura: OKAY.
TRANSLATION, YOU SHOULD BE FAR
MORE AFRAID OF YOUR FELLOW
AMERICANS THAN THAT MILLIONS OF
ILLEGAL ALIENS BEING BUZZED AND
FLOWN ALL OVER THE COUNTRY IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
GOT IT?
OF COURSE, WE ALL KNOW THAT
HUNTER BIDEN, DHS SECRETARY
HUNDRED MAYORKAS IS NOT REALLY
IN CHARGE OF THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
AS A PRACTICAL MATTER, THE
MEXICAN DRUG SYNDICATES ARE.
MILLIONS OF ILLEGALS HAVE
ALREADY CROSSED OUR BORDERS
SINCE BIDEN CAME INTO OFFICE.
IN JUST THE MONTH OF MARCH,
MARCH THAT WE JUST HAD.
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION
SAY THEY ENCOUNTERED MORTON
221,000 ILLEGALS NOW, TO GIVE
YOU A SENSE OF HOW STAGGERING
THIS NUMBER IS, WHEN TRUMP
DECLARED THE BORDER SITUATION
EMERGENCY WHICH WAS THREE YEARS
AGO, THAT NUMBER OF MONTHLY
APPREHENSIONS THAN HAD HIT
76,000.
NOW, BECAUSE MOST BUY GOODS ARE
GETTING OUR ASYLUM LAWS, ONE OF
THE FEW TOOLS THAT BORDER PATROL
AGENTS HAD HUNTER BIDEN WAS
PEDAL FORTITUDE WHICH WAS THE
TRUMP RULES THAT ALLOWED FOR
IMMEDIATE ATTORNMENT OF MIGRANTS
AT THE BORDER DUE TO THESE COVID
CONCERNS.
INTO UNDERSTAND HOW SIGNIFICANT
THIS TOOL IS, IN MARCH,
109,549th AND COUNTERS CANNOT
50 THE TOTAL WERE PROCESSED FOR
EXPULSION UNDER TITLE XLII.
21% OF ALL FAMILY UNIT
INDIVIDUALS WERE PROCESSED FOR
EXPULSION UNDER TITLE XLII AS
WELL.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT?
220,000, ABOUT HALF, IMMEDIATELY
TURNED BACK, NOT BUZZED AROUND
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE OF
TITLE XLII.
BIDEN MUST, RID OF THAT AND OF
COURSE, BECAUSE HIS TEAM
BELIEVES BORDERS ARE IMMORAL,
THEY ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF
DROPPING TITLE XLII.
BUT BECAUSE THEY NOTES JUST HOW
DETRIMENTAL THIS WILL BE TO ALL
AMERICANS BECAUSE THEY ARE
PASSING THE BUCK.
>> TITLE XLII IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITY THAT RESTS IN THE
EXCLUSIVE JURISDICTION OF THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION AND THEY DECIDE
WHETHER THAT TITLE XLII
AUTHORITY REMAINS NECESSARY.
ARE EXPECTED AS A REMINDER, IT
IS A HEALTH AUTHORITY COULD NOT
AN IMMIGRATION PLAN.
DETERMINATION ABOUT WHERE WE
STAND AND TO LIFT WAS MADE BY
THE CDC.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND.
DID THEY THINK THIS WAS A WHOLE
OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH?
DON'T YOU LOVE THAT PHRASE?
WITHOUT TITLE XLII, THE NUMBERS
OF ILLEGALS FLOODING IN WILL
DWARF THAT PUMP THOSE
POPULATIONS OF MANY AMERICAN
CITIES, EVEN STATES IN SOME
CASES BY THE END OF BIDEN'S
FIRST TERM THAT IS THE WHOLE
GOAL.
AND NOW, AMERICANS ARE GROWING
FED UP.
NEW POLLING IS SHOWING THAT THEY
RAISED THE BORDER ISSUES SECOND
ONLY TO INFLATION AS THEIR MAJOR
CONCERN.
THIS MAKES TOTAL SENSE.
OF REAL WAGES ARE STAGNATING
COULD NOT KEEPING WITH
INFLATION.
A.
SO MANY OTHER PROBLEMS ARE
EXACERBATED BY THE OPEN BORDER.
CRIME, LOCAL BUDGETS ARE BEING
PRESSED.
AT THE DRUG EPIDEMIC.
UNDERSTAND THIS.
MORE THAN 106,000 AMERICANS DIED
FROM OVERDOSES FROM
NOVEMBER 2020 TO NOVEMBER 2021.
SIMPLY PUT, BY REFUSING TO DO
ALL THAT IS NECESSARY AT THE
BORDER, BIDEN IS ALLOWING CHINA
THROUGH MEXICO TO KILL US WITH
FENTANYL.
>> THEY BOUGHT WHAT THEY THOUGHT
WAS.
FROM A DRUG DEALER ON SNAPCHAT.
>> THERE'S REALLY NO WAY TO FILL
THAT VOID.
>> Reporter: IT TURNED OUT TO
BE 100% FENTANYL.
>> Laura: TRUMP, OF COURSE,
PREDICTED ALL THIS CHAOS WOULD
HAPPEN.
SO IN THE END, YOU ARE EITHER A
PRESIDENT WHO BELIEVES IN
BORDERS OR YOU ARE NOT.
AND YOU ARE EITHER A PARTY THAT
BELIEVES IN OUR SOVEREIGN HERE
NATIONAL OR NOT.
AT FROM BUSH, TO BIDEN, THEY
FOLLOWED THE SAME PLAYBOOK.
>> IT WAS NEITHER RIGHT NOR
REALISTIC TO ROUND UP MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE, MANY WITH DEEP ROOTS
TO THE UNITED STATES AND SEND
THEM CROSS THE BORDER.
>> Laura: AND THIS WAS REPORTED
TO THE REPEATED TODAY BY BIDEN'S
DHS SECRETARY.
>> WE INHERITED A BROKEN AND HIS
MENTAL SYSTEM.
IT IS NOT BUILT TO MANAGE THE
CURRENT LEVELS AND TYPES OF
MIGRATORY FLOWS.
ONLY COMMERCE CAN PUSH CONGRESS
CAN FIX THIS.
>> Laura: AFTER IT NONE OF THEM
ARE SERIOUS ABOUT ENFORCING
EXISTING LAWS OR REMOVALS AND
AFTER NONE OF THEM PUSHED TO
TEDEN UP THE ASYLUM RULES, AND
IN BIDEN'S CASE, DROPPING
TITLE XLII, OF COURSE, MIGRANTS
ARE GOING TO RUSH THE BORDER.
OUR AGENTS' LIVES ARE ENDANGERED
AND WHEN TEXAS NATIONAL
GUARDSMEN DIED LAST WEEK TRYING
TO RESCUE IMMIGRANTS ON THE RIO
GRANDE, THESE ARE THE RESULTS OF
JOE BIDEN'S OPEN BORDER AGENDA.
THIS IS A PATTERN OVER THREE
ADMINISTRATIONS.
AND WHEN THE PUBLIC OUTCRY BILLS
AS IT IS BUILDING NOW, THEY
DAVID TO THE COMPANY AND TO.
>> WE NEED TO RESOLVE THE STATUS
OF THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS SO
THAT YOU CAN PASS AND I CAN SIGN
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
INTO LAW.
>> IT IS LONG PAST TIME TO
REFORM AN INTEGRATION SYSTEM
THAT RIGHT NOW DOES NOT SERVE
AMERICA AS WELL AS IT SHOULD.
>> President Biden: THE
IMMIGRATION REFORM IS SUPPORTED
BY EVEN THE U.S. CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
LET'S GET IT DONE ONCE AND FOR
ALL.
>> Laura: 'S REMEMBER, IT IS NOT
AMNESTY.
NO.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE MANY HOOPS
THAT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WILL
HAVE TO JUMP THROUGH.
WE PROMISE.
>> I BELIEVE THAT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO WANT TO STAY
SHOULD HAVE TO PAY A MEANINGFUL
PENALTY FOR BREAKING THE LAW TO
PAY THEIR TAXES.
TO LEARN ENGLISH.
>> President Obama: IF YOU HAVE
BEEN IN AMERICA FOR MORE THAN
FIVE YEARS, IF YOU HAVE CHILDREN
WHO ARE AMERICAN CITIZENS OR
LEGAL RESIDENTS, IF YOU
REGISTERED TO PASS A CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK.
>> President Biden: THEY GOT
TO LEARN TO SPEAK ENGLISH.
>> Laura: THEN ALL YOU LAW AND
ORDER PEOPLE YOU ARE SUBJECTED
TO AN IMMIGRATION SOB STORY.
>> President Bush: THE VAST
MAJORITY OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE DECENT PEOPLE WHO WORK HARD
TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES,
PRACTICE THEIR FAITH.
>> President Obama: THESE PEOPLE
ARE CLASSMATES, OUR FRIENDS.
>> President Biden: IT IS
BUILT AROUND KEEPING FAMILIES
TOGETHER.
>> Laura: MY FAVORITE BIDEN, I
GUESS IT WAS EIGHT YEARS AGO
DURING ANOTHER IMMIGRATION PEDAL
WHERE HE ADMITTED WHAT WE ALL
KNOW.
THEY DON'T REALLY THINK AMERICAN
CITIZENSHIP IS ALL THAT SPECIAL.
>> President Biden: 11 MILLION
PEOPLE LIVED IN THE SHADOWS.
I BELIEVE THEY ARE ALREADY
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
>> Laura: YES, HE SAID THAT.
AND CONFERENCE OF IMMIGRATION
REFORM IS JUST SHORTHAND OF
COURSE FOR GIVING AMNESTY TO, I
DUNNO, PROBABLY AT THIS POINT,
22 MILLION ILLEGALS.
AND I LOVE HOW THEY ALWAYS SAY
11 MILLION AS IF THAT NUMBER IS
PRESENT IN TIME.
SO IT IS HARD TO -- YOU LOSE
COUNT HERE.
IT IS THE THIRD OR FOURTH TIME
TO LET NECKLACE LAST 15 YEARS
WERE THERE'S SUPPOSEDLY
CONSERVATION'S ABOUT -- CONSERVE
-- CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IMMIGRATN
REFORM.
IN 2006 AND 2007 KURT BUSCH TRY
TO DO SOMETHING WITH McCAIN
AND THE DEMOCRATS.
INCLUDING YOURS TRULY, AND IT
WAS DEFEATED.
IN 2013, THERE WAS A GANG OF A
BILL AND MARCO RUBIO WAS LEADING
IT.
HE WAS OPERATING IN GOOD FAITH I
THINK.
HE WAS NEW TO THE SENATE.
HE SMARTLY STEPPED AWAY FROM IT.
THAT WENT DOWN AT THINGS AS
WELL.
BUT NOW I GUESS THEY ARE TRYING
TO DO IT ALL OVER AGAIN.
SMART CONSERVED US KNOW THAT
PREMISE OF ENFORCEMENT NEVER
COMES.
SMART CONSERVATIVES NOTE THAT
THEY START TALKING ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY WHEN THEY DO THAT.
THEY ARE GOING TO INSTALLED THE
STUFF AT THE BORDER DRUMS.
THEY ARE NOT SERIOUS AT ALL.
THEY WILL GET BETTER VIGILANTLY
BEEPS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
CROSSING.
THAT IS ABOUT IT.
THE FACT IS WE HAVE A LOT OF
POLITICIANS IN OFFICE WHO THINK
THAT ENFORCING THE BORDER IS A
MORAL CRIME.
THEY THINK BORDER ENFORCEMENT IS
FOR FASCISTS ONLY.
CLASS, THAT THEY WANT TO SATISFY
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WHICH I
WAS ONCE AN ENDLESS STREAM OF
LOW-WAGE WORKERS.
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN HAVE A DEAL
IS IF A SERIOUS ENFORCEMENT
PRESIDENT IS IN CHARGE AND OF
COURSE, WHAT WE HAD THAT IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE FINALLY GOT
BETTER CONTROL OF THE BORDER.
THE DEMOCRATS DO NOT WANT TO DO
A DEALS.
THAT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO KNOW.
WHEN A REPUBLICAN IS IN OFFICE
AGAIN.
WE WILL ENFORCE THE BORDER.
THE TRUMP REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY MARKED.
TITLE XLII WORKED.
>> THE NUMBER OF MIGRANTS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER HAS DROPPED
DRAMATICALLY.
>> ABOUT 104,000 PEOPLE WERE
APPREHENDED IN JUNE.
DIFFERENT DECLINE IN MONTHS.
AN AGREEMENT WITH MEDICAL TO
CRACKDOWN ON ASYLUM-SEEKERS FOR
CENTRAL AMERICA.
>> Laura: THAT WAS BECAUSE OF A
DEAL BETWEEN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND MEXICO.
THE PURPOSE GOING FORWARD, WE
SHOULD JUST ASSUME THAT WHEN
DEMOCRATS ARE IN CHARGE?
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE OPEN
BORDERS.
AGREEING TO ANY DEAL WITH THEM
IN CHARGE WOULD BE LIKE A GOING
TO, I DON'T KNOW, POLITICAL
EXTORTION SCHEME.
IN THE END WOULD BE WORSE, NOT
BETTER OFF.
SO PUT THE PRESSURE ON, AS
SENATORS IN MONTANA, CORTEZ IN
NEVADA, KELLY IN THE ARIZONA,
NEW HAMPSHIRE SAYS, WE SUPPORTS
COMP